Stephen Hawking was
one of the most
influential scientists
of his generation.
From black holes to The Simpsons,
his impact on science and popular
culture is hard to overestimate.
In this video we're going to look at just
three publications that shaped his career.
Number one: 'The singularities of
gravitational collapse and cosmology'
This paper was published in 1970.
It was a time when physicists were still finding some of the implications of general relativity hard to swallow,
in particular the possibility of black holes
and infinitely dense singularities.
Hawking and others had already
shown that singularities should form,
at least in an abstract mathematical setting.
In fact, in his PhD thesis, Hawking had
explored how the universe itself
might have originated from a
singularity at the beginning of time.
But in the 1970 paper, Hawking worked
with eminent physicist Roger Penrose
and showed that general relativity,
even in the real world,
really does predict singularities.
Number two: 'Black hole explosions?'
As time went on Stephen Hawking's name would
become inextricably linked with black holes.
This paper really was called 'Black hole explosions?'
with a question mark.
He had a knack for grabbing people's attention.
It describes what came to be
known as Hawking radiation
which many physicists
regard as his most important legacy.
Hawking was trying to reconcile two
seemingly incompatible theories.
One was general relativity, which works well for
describing the largest scales in the universe,
the other was quantum theory, which
describes the smallest scales.
Hawking realised that if you believe both theories,
the event horizon of a black hole should emit radiation.
He had shown that black holes are not actually black.
To this day physicists continue to argue over
the implications of Hawking radiation
and in particular about whether it erases
information from the universe,
which would violate quantum theory.
And finally, number three: 'A brief history of time'.
This is not a scientific paper
but rather a popular science book
and it is this book which would catapult Hawking
from prominent scientist
to probably the most famous scientist of his time.
It gave him a new platform as a science communicator,
a spokesperson and a cultural phenomenon.
Ever since people around the world have been
fascinated by his story, his intellect and his tenacity.
Many now know Stephen Hawking
for his characteristic synthetic voice,
his appearances on television shows
or his controversial opinions
on a whole host of issues
from AI through to alien life.
But behind the pop-culture icon, there
was a scientist whose legacy will endure.
And as Hawking himself once said:
"I hope I will be remembered for my work on black holes
and the origin of the Universe
not for things like appearing on The Simpsons."